yo what a blog here in Chinatown in
London I'm a way to London on the plane
all day actually so interesting day for
the blog you know I don't know if a lot
of you guys know this is one of the only
pieces of content I made during this era
it was the airplane rant very high in
the air back from London headed to out
New York City then go to watch it see if
it inspires another rant just that he
read a hundred emails from people that
will make it forty fifty K 30 K read
crushing read Thank You Connor he got
inspired by me but I was a spark I was
the one that had that insane thing that
I have in me that made them saying hmm
you know things that make you go home
I'm sorry
but then they had it in them and so when
I make this video what's coming from my
heart right now is maybe you're watching
this and say hmm maybe I need to hedge
you know if you work from eating p.m. to
4:00 in the morning will your dreams
come true no you might not be good
enough you might have not picked the
right product but are we living in a
world in 2012 that's so much better than
your parents and grandparents and great
grandparents generation because it
[ __ ] like me can make videos when
I'm thirty thousand [ __ ] feet in the
air
yes and because of that and because of
those opportunities because we're
networks in a way we've never seen
before because sending an email to a
hundred people and one will answer and
give you a shot matters because of that
opportunity because of 2012 I beg you I
beg you to take a shot
oh good shoot there was something oh I
know I wanted to talk about first of all
hey everybody
Airport Gary somebody's how I sign by
the way people even asking if you if you
got a book for me this I saw Mike's
signature and then I do this in there
Shelly just came back from two days with
Ryan Harwood and selling Boehner XP
ravine or media the the competition
conference I'm doing it at Wine Library
D the nope not fair I just think
everybody is now he said Sanjay I'm just
like if anybody says anything I'm a guy
the competitor conference the wine of
the Month Club the digital corks the
four DS it's been a fun kind of four or
five months of selling for me which is
not where I normally am and and it made
me think of something which is the way I
do branding I sell so infrequently that
I think some of you that are watching me
the hardest core need to hear this which
is it's okay to sell especially if you
believe in something look if you believe
in what you're selling and that's what
I'm spending a lot of time on now trying
to spend more time on really getting to
a place where I really believe in stuff
instead of just past of not creating so
it wasn't selling because I didn't
believe you know and just letting
everything come to me but as I create
these you know events Vayner experience
a lot of events very big on events
events are so valuable just watching the
four DS crew is value and like how it's
impacting their business for 10 thousand
dollars right there game and you see I
know you get the emails the wine club
like $150 worth wine for fifty five
bucks like I've just locked in
November's it's gonna make all your
Thanksgivings ridiculous the conference
$500 two-hour session in my stomping
grounds good deal compared to like other
conferences that I speak at but you're
getting the wine for free or you're
getting the talk for free and you're
getting the wine so like I'm very
fascinated because I'm putting more
pressure on myself to create things that
I really believe in which then allows me
to sell more and I just think for a lot
of you
selling the ask the right hook is very
difficult your passive you like the idea
of like feeling good about like giving
out content this and that when you
believe in something you can sell it and
you should put more pressure on yourself
to create things that you believe in
biggest problem is so many of you sell
[ __ ] you don't believe in you're just
doing it for the [ __ ] money you're
gonna [ __ ] lose that I don't like
let's go to London in the and the spirit
of always trying to add little hacks
tried something new one on this London
trip usually would go late land seems
like a whole tough day and so went early
today to London landed now it's late
here honestly at home my plan was to do
a lot of work land here and then and
then go to sleep and just being a good
rhythm unfortunately I haven't been
sleeping much as I'd like by the way
real quick
always getting 6 7 8 but got some fives
and sixes in round got a little tired so
a glass of wine and conked out so didn't
work out but here's the point why I'm
sharing it with you need to try
different things and different patterns
London wasn't working I wasn't as
productive and I was always very very
tired so I tried something new
not exactly actually keep my game plan
but the fact that I'm trying something
new it makes it ROI positive
10:14 the competitor business conference
next post on snapchat swipe it up check
it out yo what a blog here in Chinatown
in London driver explaining it to Jordan
d-roc 11 p.m. at night same old same old
thank you I want to wrap this up very
simply as much as things change like
[ __ ] Shake Shack in the middle of
London things stay the same and for me
that's very simple people innovating all
around voice Instagram all that [ __ ] but
it's the grind it's the message it's
doing the right thing it's the context
of the content the next 20 years I'm
gonna say the same [ __ ] the platforms
are gonna change your attention is gonna
move like that bag just moved but it
games the [ __ ] thing see ya so I
think when I get the praise its what the
[ __ ] does that have to do with me when I
get [ __ ] on I'm like that's on me and
I'll fix it
and I think those either was a I said it
really quick but it's [ __ ]
accountability its accountability and
ownership when you suck and it's passing
on the credit when you [ __ ]
and that's it and that's me and that's
my makeup and that's why I'm winning in
life and that's why I'm always gonna win
because when you are [ __ ] a hundred
percent accountable and you know your
[ __ ] they're garbage they're 100%
accountable when there's an issue and
when you pass on the praise when you're
getting it
you become fundamentally undefeated
unbeatable I'm straight-up unbeatable
because my head will never get gassed up
enough ever when I'm getting it good and
and I'll never believe it's me and when
it's bad I'll never point the [ __ ]
pit finger than anybody else
while you [ __ ] finger pointers
pointing everywhere everybody's [ __ ]
pointing fingers pointing them
everywhere it's everybody's [ __ ]
fault with yourself
the country the environment your parents
school system loss and
circumcenter force
there's tragedies and crimes and child
abuse and real bad stuff not saying it's
not real and say for the 95% of you it's
a mighty cepting
perspective expected everything grounded
in my perspective
number two high number too low
it's about that what it's good it's
about me when it's bad that's me
that's what I got for you
it's a mindset and I never waver it's a
[ __ ] hundred percent
we have my badges
lucky that [ __ ] myself
every spotlight every sound bite
everybody who gave
it's just a beautiful morning in mom
than anybody against us so what's going
on let me answer some questions now what
can I help you guys with